[Music]
good morning Hank it's Tuesday July 17th
the day of my punishment Hank in your
punishment video by the way pretty
hilarious you said that you didn't know
where to get green hair dye but you can
spray on I didn't know where to get
green spray-on hair dye either but
fortunately Indianapolis has something
called 86th Street 86th Street is like a
normal Street except it contains all
possible commercial entities so this
morning I got up I got on 86th Street I
went to the Walgreens I went to the
Salvation Army I went to the goodwill
and I went to the party store I got
green spray-on hair dye but I think
that's gonna have to actually wait until
Thursday since you didn't do yours yet I
got really really really really big
pants look huh they're huge and I got a
belt for my really really really huge
pants I think it's a girl belt but I
don't think it matters I mean you just
want lipstick now since my punishment is
to recreate a mix of two pictures first
this picture boy and secondly this
picture I've also had to find some
metals Hank I have three metals first my
Alabama Library Association author award
second the medal I got for being an
audio Award finalist and third a medal I
created myself using an Ethernet cable
and a button that a nerdfighter gave me
that says ask me how you can join the
evil baby orphanage oh and also I got a
bow tie all right Hank let's do it
I know what you're wondering Hank you're
wondering first why is your chest making
noise and second where did all the
metals go okay okay I gotta get psyched
up oh I forgot about the glasses I can't
very well recreate this picture without
the glasses do you like these No these
make me look like the bastard child of
Harry Potter and Harry Caray fortunately
I have these unfortunately I can't see
anything out of them where are you we're
gonna do it this time
[Music]
Oh
really Hank is this a punishment for me
or for the audience
[Music]
oh just here
roll sound
Hank I'll see you tomorrow
just Sunday
and dancing I can't see anything dancing
dancing and okay okay nothing's broke
[Music]